ce qui va nous prendre plusieurs
mois si on est isolé
la parole est à monsieur
patrick et dan parks ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'éducation nationale
madame la ministre vous aurez au
moins réussi une chose de cours
de ce quinquennat avec notre
politique
éducative
faire cuire les paniers de
l'enseignement public vers
l'enseignement privé
d'ailleurs ce n'est plus d'une
fuite c'est un véritable exode
ce week-end le journal le monde
développe largement fait m et
vos propres services fournissent
des éléments pour l'alimenter
ainsi une note de décembre
dernier émanant de votre ami
mystère expliquons massif
à une hausse inévitable du
nombre d'élèves accueillis
dans les établissements
d'enseignement privés
cette progression est très
significatif puisque le privé
augmente de dix mille élèves
dans le secondaire et d'autres
administrations dans le
par ailleurs le public en perd
quasiment autant
il ya donc bien en effet de
vases communicants
on peut donc elle dément en
conclure que la situation
actuelle est liée à lienz
à une défiance à l'égard des
réformes que vous avez tenté
il a pu le faire au cours du
cacao
ainsi toutes les enquêtes
pointe des dysfonctionnements
que vous avez largement
accentué en cinq ans rythmes
scolaires chamboulé section
bilangue fermé programmes revus
à la baisse et réforme du coup
neige extrêmement désastreuse
alors madame la ministre quand
est-ce que nos élèves pourquoi
prendre principalement le
français plante allez-vous
enfin mettre l'action sur les
sciences pour que nous puissions
renouer avec notre fantastique
culture scientifique quand allez
vous renseigner à nouveau
l'histoire et la géographie
nationale pour que les écoliers
d'eau qui viennent
les connaître et puis tant
qu'à être clair
décidément madame la ministre
vous avez oublié tout relatif
même ceux d'une véritable
école de la république
la parole est à madame najat
vallaud-belkacem ème minute de
l'éducation nationale
alors que la demande de
réparation
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les
députés ump le député
patrick head
comme de tous actes et non de
l'entendre déploré donc si je
comprends bien l'augmentation
des dettes étatiques dans le
privé et en même temps
soutenir françois fillon
ils veulent faire sauter le
verrou un débat important
d'enseignement prix des mac
slimane dans le pays c'est à
dire installer un grand marché
concurrentiel de l'éducation
dans laquelle on le perd 1 5
point toujours les familles qui
ont le plus les moyens de payer
un prix par le parquet raul
albiol
après l'attaqué perpétrée en
carrière
loin des caricatures dans lequel
vous nous avez habitués alors
que nous disons les chiites que
le plus d'élèves comptent à
terme à l'éloignement goût de
l'environnement tryba la
rentrée 2013 et de répéter
revenir bulle de pourtant des
roses de 12 2% il s'agit d'une
évolution une marginale que
l'on constate depuis des années
depuis 20 ans même pour tout
vous dire
cinq ans par exemple l'impact
académique très concrètement
et bien on voit l'effet de la
démographie vous avez en effet
121 élèves supplémentaires
dans le privé mais vous en avez
de 180 autres supplémentaires
dans le public et le secrétaire
général de l'enseignement
catholique lui-même animer cet
effet démographique bien il a
manqué la réforme du collège
oubliant qu'elle a vocation à
renforcer l'attractivité de
tous les collèges et quel
était le meilleur moyen de
lutter contre la fuite vers
d'autres établissements vous
oubliez également parce que ça
vous arrange que la réforme du
collège s'applique et nous
attendons dans les mêmes termes
dans l'enseignement privé car
dans l'enseignement public alors
mettez-vous à l'aps soyons un
peu sérieux épique
six équipes en panne et parfois
de certaines familles a
préféré un établissement
d'enseignement privé
c'étaient les dépôts de
décliner lequel on doit garder
en permanence sur la gueule de
la réunion
il n'en fallait pas tant
l'école de la république qui
connaît de très nombreuses
années une petite des réformes
qu'il entend améliorer les
rapports entre les parents et
l'école par exemple et qu'il va
permettre au point d'avoir des
établissements aujourd'hui
similaire de l'établissement
qu'elle nous réclamons
davantage de mixité sociale sa
voix pour le privé comme pour
le public et il est d'ailleurs
allé assez loin